♪
>> Harold: CANCELLATION CHAOS
ROCKING AMERICAN AIRLINES.
AFTER THE GROUND IN NEARLY 2,000
FLIGHTS OVER THE WEEKEND FOR THE
PROBLEMS CONTINUING TODAY WITH
300 FLIGHTS CANCELED.
BLAMING HIGH WINDS AND STAFFING
SHORTAGES WHILE FRUSTRATED
PASSENGERS ARE SOUNDING OFF.
>> I LOOKED AT MY PHONE TEN OR
20 MINUTES BEFORE AND JUST GOT
CANCELED OUT OF NOWHERE.
>> EVERYTHING I CHECKED PUTS ME
IN A REALLY LONG LINE AND I NOT
ANSWERING QUESTIONS.
>> OTHER AIRLINES HAVE BEEN
CRIPPLED BY SIMILAR DELAYS IN
RECENT WEEKS AND EXPERTS NOW
WARNING STAFF SHORTAGES COULD
WREAK HAVOC ON HOLIDAY TRAVEL.
LOOK AT AND WE TO STOP THE
INSULATION, LOOK AT ME AS
PASSENGERS DO TO BE HELPFUL?
>> Sandra: THEY COULD RESEND
THE MASK MANDATE AND VACCINE
MANDATES AND SEE WHAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO DO TO STAND UP FOR
THEIR RIGHTS.
NOT GOING TO HIRE LAWYERS TO SUE
ALTHOUGH SOME ARE DOING THAT.
THEY ARE ENGAGING IN CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE AND PROVING THEY
ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO WORKED
FOR MOST OF THE PANDEMIC AND YOU
WERE GOING TO TELL THEM NOW
THEY'RE GOING TO LOSE THEIR JOBS
OR THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LOSE
THEIR JOBS OVER SOMETHING THEY
MAY NOT NEED OR DO NOT WANT.
SOUTHWEST OR AMERICAN ESSAY, I
WAS JUST WEATHER-RELATED,
HAPPENS AT ONE OR TWO AIRPORTS.
PEOPLE WHO KNOW AIR TRAFFIC
CONTROLLERS ARE PILOTS AND SAY
THIS IS OUR WAY OF SAYING THIS
IS NOT JUST ABOUT US BUT ABOUT
PEOPLE WE WORK WITH SO WE ARE
JUST HAVING ISSUES AND IT'S
OBVIOUS WHAT THE PROBLEM IS AND
THE CEOs OF THESE COMPANIES
AND BY THE WAY, WHAT WERE TALL
TOLD THAT IT WAS COMPLETELY SAFE
THAT WE CAN HAVE ALL THE SYSTEMS
IN PLACE AND THAT IT WASN'T
GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE ON THE
PLANE, WHY HAS THAT CHANGED NOW?
>> Sandra: THAT WILL CHANGE
THINGS BECAUSE COMPANIES ARE
LOSING A LOT OF MONEY PIT
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES KNOWN FOR ITS
GREAT CUSTOMER SERVICE HAD TO
CANCEL 2,000 FLIGHTS COSTING
$75 MILLION SO THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO MAKE CHANGES BUT THEM
SAYING THAT IT'S THE WEATHER IS
IT NECESSARILY AN EXCUSE, THE
LABOR UNIONS OR MORNING FOR
MONTHS THAT BECAUSE THEY HAD
SCALED BACK SO MUCH STAFF DURING
THE PANDEMIC, THEY HAD FORCED
EARLY RETIREMENTS ON SO MANY
THAT IF THERE WAS EVER A SNARL
IN THE SYSTEM OR BAD WEATHER
THAT MEANT THEY WOULD HAVE TO
CONNECT FLIGHT CREWS AND PILOTS
TO DIFFERENT AREAS OR DISPERSE
THEM TO OTHER AIRPORTS OR
WHATEVER IT WAS THAT THEY WOULD
SERIOUSLY HAVE PROBLEMS.
THAT IS HAPPENING.
THE LABOR UNION WORN TO THIS
WOULD HAPPEN IN BAD WEATHER AS
PART OF IT.
IT'S ALL CONNECTED.
>> Harold: WE DON'T THINK IT'S
WEATHER, IT COULD BE WEATHER AND
THE STAFFING SHORTAGES.
I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
>> Sandra: MAKES A BAD
SITUATION WORSE.
>> Greg: SOUNDS MORE LIKE HOT
AIR.
>> Sandra: JOKES ON A MONDAY.
>> Greg: I THINK IT'S THE
VACCINE MANDATE THING AND IT'S
TIME THAT WE START TALKING ABOUT
EXEMPTIONS FOR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS, PEOPLE WHO MAKE THE
WORLD GO ROUND AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE FIREMEN AND COPS BECAUSE
WE HAVE ISSUES HERE, PARAMEDICS,
HANDSOME MUSCULAR TALK SHOW
HOSTS LIKE ME THIS ALL OR
NOTHING THING IS A HUGE PROBLEM
AND WE ARE KIND OF FREELANCING
THIS ALL OVER THE PLACE SO
PEOPLE DON'T GET SUED AND WE
TALKED ABOUT MY OPINION IS
ALWAYS THAT LIABILITY NOW IS
TRUMPING COMMON SENSE.
WE ARE MORE SCARED OF THE RISK
OF BEING SUED THAN THE RISK OF
COVID THEY HAPPEN TO WORK
TOGETHER.
>> Jesse: WHAT'S YOUR BIGGEST
MUSCLE?
>> Greg: I'D HAVE TO GO WITH
MY PECKS, I WILL SHOW YOU MY
CALVES AT THE BREAK.
YOU DON'T WANT A BIG HEART.
>> Harold: YOU'VE BEEN A
PROPONENT OF THE VACCINE AND
HAVE SHARED THAT YOU BELIEVE
THAT EVERYONE GOT VACCINATED, WE
WOULDN'T HAVE TO WEAR A MASK AND
EVERYTHING WOULD BE BETTER.
WHEN ONE TO KEEP THAT INDUSTRY
INTACT AND NOW YOU HAVE THOSE
WHO DON'T WANT TO GET
VACCINATED, STAFF SHORTAGE AND
WHETHER COULD BE PART OF IT AS
WELL BUT DO YOU THINK THEY HAVE
A HIGHER RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE
THE VACCINE THAN OTHERS BECAUSE
OF WHAT WE AS TAXPAYERS DID TO
KEEP THE AIRLINE INDUSTRY INTACT
BY GIVING THEM MONEY DURING THE
PANDEMIC?
>> Jesse: EVERYBODY GOT MONEY
AND THEY ARE STILL GOING MONEY
OUT.
FEW THINGS IN LIFE ARE MORE
AGONIZING THAN FLIGHT
CANCELLATIONS.
MAYBE A SPEEDING TICKET OR MAYBE
WHEN YOU SIT DOWN TO DINNER AND
THE FOOD TAKES FOREVER AND YOU
ARE STARVING.
>> Harold: ARE YOU PROJECTING?
>> Jesse: IT AFFECTS THE
COUNTRY'S MOOD AND THE COUNTRY
IS IN A FOUL MOOD BECAUSE OF
THINGS LIKE THIS AND THIS IS BY
USING 70% OF AMERICANS THINK THE
COUNTRY IS GOING THE WRONG
DIRECTION BUT IT ALSO GOES TO
COMPETENCE WHEN THIS IS
SOMETHING DOGGING JOE BIDEN.
AMERICANS HAVE EXPECTATIONS.
WE EXPECT FLIGHTS TO TAKE OFF ON
TIME.
WE EXPECT FIREFIGHTERS COME ON
WE EXPECT SHELVES TO BE FULL.
THESE ARE THINGS WE EXPECT AS
AMERICANS BECAUSE WE ARE A RICH
AND WEALTHY AND VERY ADVANCED
NATION AND WHEN THESE THINGS
DON'T HAPPEN, WE SAY WHY ARE
THESE THINGS HAPPENING?
MY CAN WE LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY?
WHEN YOU ASK JOE BIDEN WHY CAN'T
WE HAVE THIS COUNTRY THAT WE
EXPECT TO HAVE?
HE JUST MUMBLES A BUNCH OF
GIBBERISH AND ADJUST -- THE
DALLAS MORNING NEWS, THIS IS HOW
THIS ARTICLE STARTED, LET'S
PERSONALIZE THIS.
MARK AND HIS WIFE HAD A
CARIBBEAN GETAWAY PLAN TO
CELEBRATE HER RECENT RETIREMENT.
INSTEAD OF THE BEACH VACATION,
THE COUPLE HAS BEEN STRANDED IN
CHARLOTTE'S BUSY AIRPORTS AND
SATURDAY MORNING.
>> Greg: IS A GREAT AIRPORT.
>> Jesse: HAVE YOU BEEN TO
CHARLOTTE?
THE AIRPORT?
WOULD YOU RATHER BE IN
TURKS AND CAICOS?
>> Greg: I'VE BEEN TO BOTH.
>> Jesse: YOU WANT HER TO SLIP
INTO A JACUZZI WITH HER HUSBAND
AND ORDER A LITTLE RUM PUNCH
WITH WHAT ARE THOSE CAUGHT DELMA
CALLED, AN UMBRELLA, GET A
SECOND ONE AND THEN GET SOME
MAPS AND SHOULD BE CELEBRATING
THEIR RETIREMENT LIKE THAT, NOT
AT A STRANDED AIRPORT.
FIRST HE STRANDS PEOPLE IN
AFGHANISTAN AND NOW THE
CHARLOTTE AIRPORT.
THE BAND IS STILL IN EFFECT